انت ترى بان هذا النموذج للبرلمان افضل من
البرلمان الحزبي اللي بيتشكل فعلا من
اغلبيه تحكم ومعارضه تراقب طريقه الحكم
اقصد الحكومه المجال التنفيذي يعني
نحن نقول وان لكل بلد ظروفه ولكل دوله
خصائصها ولكل مجتمع بطبيعه الحال يعني
وضعيته الخاصه ونحن الان نمر بمرحله يعني
جديده هذه المرحله خرجنا من الحكم الفردي
بعد
14 جانفي 2011 انتقلنا الى
نظام
رئاسي معدل ونظام برلماني معدل هذا النظام
لم ينجح في قرار يعني مسار سياسي مستقر
بدليل وانه
الاحزاب التي شاركت في الحكم تقول صحيح
اننا شاركنا في الحكم ولكن لا نتحمل يعني
مسؤوليه الفشل لانه لم تكن لنا الكلمه
الاخيره في الحكم
وبطبيعه الحال ما هو مطلوب هو ان من يتحمل
المسؤوليه مسؤوليه الحكم يجب ان يتحمل
مسؤوليه النجاح ومسؤوليه الفشل ولذلك يعني
ادى الامر الى اتخاذ تدابير 25 جويليه
واختيار نظام حسب الدستور
الحالي يعني نظام رئاسي يكون فيه رئيس
الوظيفه التنفيذيه مسؤوله عن النجاح
ومسؤوله على الفشل ويحاسب على النجاح كما
يحاسب على الفشل
والمجلس التشريعي يقوم بصلاحياته سواء
يعني في التشريع وذلك من خلال النظر في
مشاريع القوانين التي تقدمها الوظيفه
التنفيذيه او من خلال المقترحات القوانين
التي يقدمها النواب وكذلك دوره الرقابي في
عمل الحكومه ويتمثل دور الرقابي في عمل
الحكومه في
امكانيه توجيه اسئله الى الحكومه في خصوص
مواضيع معينه في امكانيه توجيه استجوابات
لاعضاء الحكومه واللي رئيسه الحكومه في
معاينه وله كذلك
بمعيه منزلات والاقليم الذي سيبعث في
القريب العاجل امكانيه لايح اعداد لائحه
لهم ضد الحكومه وفي سوره المصادقه عليها
فما يترتب عنها سياسيا هو ان رئيس الدوله
اما ان يغير الحكومه او انه يقوم بحل
البرلمان وعند ذلك ترجع الكلمه للشعب في
اختيار من يمثله